healthcare workers uh if everyone gets
vaccinated you could use the argument
their work will be a lot easier uh er
nurses are probably looking forward to
something like that uh but james
patterson and matt everson are here
right now they both co-authored a book
that's actually pretty fascinating i
understand it started before the
pandemic or the planning of it er nurses
true stories from america's greatest
unsung heroes uh james and matt are
joining me now gentlemen very good to
have you good to be here good to be here
you know it's interesting guys and i was
not meaning to insult you but obviously
every time we have authors on i want to
make sure i read their book and i
thought of the subject and
both great writers and have a great
history of great books behind you i
thought how riveting is this going to be
uh it was both funny and tragic and you
could make me laugh and make me cry but
the day in and day out of what er nurses
deal with uh beyond anything coveted
related it just just hit home
was that the thinking behind it if i can
begin with you first james
oh man
we're getting
getting your producer or something
i apologize
for that um
it
hopefully will correct that my producer
is talking if you could stop talking
yeah
go ahead james
uh no you know neil it's exactly
when we did everybody loves nurses per
se but they have no idea what a mind
blower their their situation is and and
when we were doing the interviews it was
like it just would knock us out and i
think people reading this book would be
the same thing they have no idea as you
said the humor
the the emotion and and just the the the
hourly stress it's unbelievable what
these people do unbelievably it will
blow your mind to read this book i i'm
not just trying to sell books but it
will change how you if you love nurses
you'll love them even more uh if you
respect them you respect them even more
you know man it's amazing because some
of them come from all different types of
backgrounds and i i remember there was
one nurse who had served in afghanistan
and found the experience of just
stealing an er a heck of a lot more
challenging than anything encountered
over there that was remarkable
yeah well it really is well matt knows
about that
well i'm just going to say you know
these these men and women are are
literally deployed their entire careers
i mean they
every shift every day every week every
month every year they are dealing with
every
worst case of worst cases routinely and
they deal with it with such with such
great determination i mean i hate to be
cliche about heroes among us but they
really aren't angels among us
which i'm sure you experienced when you
read it it's just story after story you
got the 600 pound woman and how they
would deal with that you have the
pregnant man
you have uh this nurse who she fell in
love with this husband and wife the
husband was dying and she said well what
could bring some joy to his life and she
said i love that
his dog his golden retriever and she
said you know what i can't do it but i'm
gonna do it and she snuck the golden
retriever into the into the uh the
hospital room and and and she's crying
and the couple are crying and the dog is
licking the tears off of the guy it's
just amazing and it's one after the
other in terms of the
yeah
stories
just supposed against them getting
cursed out or hit or whatever i mean
yeah you know there's yeah they get hit
they get hit yeah
that that blew me away but you know matt
there's been a change in thinking i mean
in health care workers and then the
whole dust up over the mandates for them
getting vaccinated we should stress here
i believe this was not in you know
emergency room nurses and that sort of
thing or doctors it was at lower levels
but there was sort of like a
a swing in sentiment toward them uh as a
result what did you make of that matt
well you know it was kind of interesting
neil in that we did as you said we
started this uh you know in 2019 before
you know anybody really had thought
deeply about kovitz so all of the
interviews kind of took place in real
time you know nobody knew about
vaccination
you know they these these men and women
were just
leading with their chin every day and as
jim says you know they they of all of us
they were the most prepared and they
were the most courageous and so you know
you kind of follow this trajectory all
the way to where we are now and it's
it's a little baffling in one sense uh
you know we never had the opportunity to
really talk about shots and mandates and
stuff like that they they took their
credit you know these men and women just
wanted to save people
whenever and however they could
you know it's funny too guys i was
thinking in my own case because
everything comes back to me i always
find everything comes back to me but
james one thing that struck me is uh
having recently tested positive for
covet i'm okay now i don't want you guys
wearing uh but i'm thinking of how they
isolate you and they want to put you in
a closet and all the things that because
they're taking and in the early days of
the pandemic these guys
were exposed to all of this endangering
their own lives and by extension
everyone around them their family and
everything else just dealing with this
selflessly without a word
that's what struck me
yeah that and also the fact that they're
used to human contact and one nurse was
talking about how
here's this poor woman that's dying and
her family can't be there and and this
nurse just finally said she's you know
behind the mask in the whole thing and
she just just holding this woman's hand
just so the woman can feel that somebody
cares somebody in that room cares about
her as a human
but you know
you know we look at people when they get
if you think about it guys you know far
better than i after the book when you go
to the emergency room you're not there
to check it to a hotel you're hurt
you're hurting and you're angry you're
with relatives or others who are
concerned and angry and they have to
deal with all of that what did you learn
from that and about their temperament
yeah matt
yeah i was going to say you know neil i
mean there's only three things that
happen you you go in and you go out you
go in and you go to icu or you go in and
you pass away and you know you you
realize that these are incredibly
emotionally and physically and mentally
tough men and women and i mean they
don't suffer fools you know lightly uh
they're the cowboys of nursing um but
they're so
empathetic and sympathetic as well even
the toughest of the tough nurse ratchets
out there still
has this unbelievable yeah you know yeah
tenderness
it makes brings tears to your eyes just
just talking about it
you know if i ever wanted to write a
book or matt and i wanted to write a
book about the underbelly of this
country i wouldn't know where to start
but now i do go to emergency rooms
because they see this stuff every day
every day they people come in
and with these unbelievable stories and
unbelievable things you know people burn
their kids it's i thought the first time
i read or heard one of the stories i'm
going with that's weird no it happens a
lot it happens a lot it's an ordinary
thing in emergency rooms but it's just
as i said i mean you know people will
sit there and go oh i don't know if i
want to read about nurses this will blow
your mind it will blow your mind you
will you will there was one nurse where
you had a bot podcast and she was a
moderator and she'd given the book to
her mother
over the weekend and her mother showed
up on sunday she was weeping and she
said i had no idea what you do honey
this i mean i read this book and i i
have so i mean she just was weeping
because she she finally understood what
nurses really do we just sold the thing
to one of the networks because there's
there's no television show that's been
done about the nurses that is real that
gets at what they do you know they're
always with the doctors doctors doctors
you see the doctor for five minutes the
nurse is there all day
yeah the doctors come in sort of like
elvis they have to you're first i'm mom
don't get me wrong
all right but your first contact is that
is that nurse and and they're
they're dealing with some genuinely
hurting people but a lot of times when
you guys bring it out i want to give the
book away some genuinely crazy people so
they have to sort out whether this
person is in real danger or this is just
someone who has some other issues how do
they do that
i think that's interesting though in the
beginning when the go ahead matt yeah
no i'm just gonna say i think that you
know there's some some incredible
instinct that comes on and i i will
before i turn it back to jim i was just
gonna say neil you know you we also got
to realize these are
our advocates i mean when you go into
the er
this guy or guys that is with you or
this group they are 100 going to bat for
you come hell or high water against
anybody um so you know
understand that so you know that that i
threw that in just as a preface of this
how do they do it um they're they're
just
when necessary they will argue with the
doctors and go no no no you've got to
pay attention to what's going on here
i've been watching this patient all day
yeah
i i was thinking of the comedian brian
regan he has a skit that he does about
you know going to the emergency room and
how you get attention and that you have
to number your pain level and it goes
back and forth but they do know
something intrinsically about whether
this one should be put ahead of this one
but oh yeah i'm thinking we you know
they're how do they
came out several times where they'll say
listen if we're not paying attention
don't be don't be too worried get
nervous when we all come running to see
you that's when you that's when you get
a little scared
you know we all think of the scary or
the the the the dangerous part of our
jobs for me guys is when the prompter
goes down and that's a crisis uh i'm
thinking of these guys and uh
they're life and death issues and i i'm
just thinking we thought about it we
were mind about it in a way a good thing
about covet but we don't really
appreciate it and what they deal with
because you know you said in the
underbelly uh but it's it's sometimes
even worse than that
yeah yeah yeah well look i mean they
pull back a curtain this guy's having a
heart attack they pull back the next
curtain this kid
put out half of their you know what i
mean it's just it's constant it's just
unbelievable a lot of people like grey's
anatomy this is way beyond grey's
anatomy and and but as you said a lot of
it is very funny too which is and that's
how you keep your sanity
no it's it's a joy but i learned from
you guys in reading this book that if
you're behind one of those curtains in
the emergency room saying stupid things
like do you know who i am
doesn't really work doesn't it
yeah
no it is
shut your shut your mouth and just say
yes that's exactly right that's it
it's really a great book guys i urge
everyone um to read it because it puts
life in perspective and whatever
bitching you're having um they have
reason to to do that
tenfold uh
exactly no politics at all guys thank
you very very much we need stories like
this they're good stories hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else